buongiorno come posso aiutarla no guardi
io mi occupo di prateria di lusso non di
casi umani
no dicevo ho visto qualcosa di suo
gradimento benvenuta solo guardare a
farmi perdere il tempo perché tanto non
coprirà nulla questa qui nero dico
subito
e questa viene 5.490 euro
se posso permettermi di consigliare
qualcosa di diverso tipo questa porta
monete ma signora questa e una pochette
di super tendenza che indossano tutte le
tic toc air si informi mi faccia
indovinare ci vuole pensare
torna tra un po mi dica pure la frase
magica di chi ha capito che ha sbagliato
negozio signora franca che piaceri
rivederla e suo marito non deve essere
facile stare al governo in un momento
del genere non lo dica nessuno ma le ho
messo da parte un pezzo unico
una borsa unica al mondo ha solo per lei
ovviamente nell'attesa champagne e
ottimo acquisto per qualsiasi cosa mi
chiami pure almè numero personale a
presto